La montée de la planète des singes est
considérée comme le premier film d'action en direct
à jouer et à être raconté du point
de vue d'un animal sensible, un personnage
aux qualités humaines qui peut
élaborer des stratégies, organiser et finalement mener
une révolution une autre
réalisation historique  car l'image était son
tournage d'effets visuels et son
travail de capture de performances sur des emplacements pratiques en
dehors d'une scène sonore et cela
m'a permis en tant que César d'interagir comme
jamais auparavant avec les autres acteurs ici,
vous verrez César afficher son
indignation et sa tendresse alors qu'il vient à
la  l'aide de son ami Charles joué par
John Lithgow qui a aidé à élever César
depuis qu'il était un bébé chimpanzé mais qui souffre maintenant
de la maladie d'
Alzheimer  question que faisiez-vous
j'ai une voiture arrêtez-la j'en ai fini avec la
police
il va mâcher reste là